learn about Link in this Advanced
c-sharp course Gavin long teaches this
course he is an experienced developer
and course creator and also a free code
Camp team member link provides a set of
operators that enable developers to
query protect and filter data in arrays
Collections and other data sources it
can be used to query and manipulate data
from databases XML documents and net
objects
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long I've been
a full stack software engineer for over
20 years about three years ago I created
an advanced c-sharp course on the
gavinlan YouTube channel you'll find the
gavinlan YouTube channel at this
location and you'll see a playlist for
the advanced c-sharp course on the
homepage of the gavinlan YouTube channel
here is the URL for the advanced c-sharp
course playlist the idea behind the
course was to explain the more advanced
c-sharp features of the language in an
easy to understand way to help c-sharp
developers who are familiar with the
basics of the language Advance their
skills to the next level the course may
also help those developers who may use
the advanced features of c-sharp like
for example Link in their day-to-day
tasks but perhaps don't fully understand
the Technologies at a deeper level free
code Camp has kindly allowed me to share
a subset of the advanced c-sharp course
it's the seventh part of the advanced
c-sharp course with you on the free code
Camp YouTube channel so in this video
we'll look in detail at a set of
Technologies named Link Link stands for
language integrated query and is very
powerful where sophisticated queries can
be made against collections of objects
and for example you can perform
filtering ordering and grouping
operations on data sources with a
minimum of code I hope you enjoy this
course and benefit from it
[Music]
hi and welcome to the first part of a
video series on link
this video is also the first part of the
seventh tutorial in an advanced c-sharp
course later in this tutorial we're
looking at a code example to help with
our understanding of Link but let's
first answer the question what is link
link stands for language integrated
query
link is defined in the Microsoft docs as
the name for a set of Technologies based
on the integration of query capabilities
directly into the c-sharp language
link was originally released as a major
part of NET Framework 3.5 in 2007
here is a paragraph
from the Microsoft docs which provides
an excellent overview of what link is
language integrated query link is the
name for a set of Technologies based on
the integration of query capabilities
directly into the c-sharp language
traditionally
queries against data are expressed as
simple strings without type checking at
compile time or intellisense support
furthermore you have to learn a
different query language for each type
of data source SQL databases
XML documents various web services and
so on
with link a query is a first class
language construct just like classes
methods events
you write queries against strongly typed
collections of objects by using language
keywords and familiar operators
the link family of Technologies provides
a consistent query experience for
objects link to objects relational
databases linked to SQL and XML link to
XML
note that you can write link queries in
c-sharp for SQL Server databases XML
documents ado.net datasets and any
collection of objects that support the I
enumerable interface or the generic I
enumerable interface
so for example you can perform link
queries against collection types like an
array generic list generic dictionary
generic Q generic stack Etc
basically any collection type that
implements the I enumerable interface or
the generic I enumerable interface
link support is also provided by Third
parties for many web services and other
database implementations
you can create custom providers using I
queryable
custom providers will not be discussed
in detail in this video series
if you would like to learn more about
implementing your own custom provider
please navigate to this URL
in this video series we'll primarily
focus on linked to objects and link to
entities
linked to entities provides language
integrated query link support that
enables developers to write queries
Against The Entity framework conceptual
model using either Visual Basic or
visual c-sharp
so Entity framework core is a modern
object database mapper for net it
supports link queries change tracking
updates and schema migrations
Entity framework core or EF core can be
used to work with many databases
including SQL databases on-premises and
Azure sqlite MySQL postgres and Azure
Cosmos DB
in this video series we won't look at
link to data set or link to XML please
navigate to this URL for more
information on linked dataset and please
information on linked to XML
to get started with link in this video
we'll focus on link to objects so that
we can first get a basic idea of what
the implementation of Link looks like in
code and how it can be used for querying
c-sharp collections
so in the spirit of cross-platform
Development I've decided to demonstrate
this code example on my Mac platform
using visual studio 2019 for Mac
Community Edition
if you have a Mac platform and wish to
follow along on your Mac and you don't
yet have Visual Studio installed
you are able to download and install
Visual Studio Community Edition 2019
free of charge from this location all
links mentioned in this video are
available Below in the description
if you are using a Windows OS please
don't let the fact that I'm using a Mac
platform put you off following along
with this tutorial in terms of the code
example that we'll create in this video
the coding experience using visual
studio for Mac is almost exactly the
same as the coding experience using
visual Studio for Windows so this should
not be a barrier for a learner to follow
along with this demonstration
if you haven't yet installed Visual
Studio 2019 on your windows platform
please view a video created by this
channel which provides a guide to
installing Visual Studio 2019 Community
Edition free of charge
so firstly let's create a.net core
console application
let's name this project the pretend
company application
before we write calling client code in
the main method we are going to add two
standard Library projects
let's first add a standard Library
project named TCP data
let's then add another standard Library
project named TCP extensions
foreign
so let's now go to our project that we
named TCP data let's delete the class
that has been automatically generated
for the TCP data project
let's add a new class named employee
let's add six autoimplemented properties
to the employee class ID as int first
name as string last name as string
annual salary as decimal is manager as
Boolean and lastly Department ID as int
okay
let's add another class to the TCP data
project
let's name this class Department
let's add three Auto implemented
properties to our department class
ID as int short name as string and long
name as string let's add a class named
data to our TCP data project let's make
this class a static class
so let's add two public static methods
to the data class
let's first create a static method named
get employees which returns a generic
list strongly typed as employee let's
ensure
that we include the appropriate using
directive for the use of generic list
objects at the top of our code editor
so let's include a using directive to
the
system.collections.generic namespace
like this
let's write the code to add some made up
employee records to a generic list that
is strongly typed with the user-defined
type employee
foreign
let's write code to return the list of
employee records to the calling client
code
foreign
let's add another static method and
let's name this method get departments
this method also returns a generic list
object but this generic list object is
strongly typed as Department
let's write the codes to add some made
up Department Records to a generic list
that is strongly typed with the
user-defined type Department
foreign
let's write code to return the list of
Department Records to the calling client
code
foreign
so as you can see the get employees
method returns a list of employee
records and the get departments method
returns a list of Department Records
so in order to gain an understanding for
how Link Works let's ensure that we
properly understand two fundamental
concepts I.E the concept of extension
methods and the concept of Lambda
expressions
so let's go to our TCP extensions
project
let's delete the class that was
auto-generated by Visual Studio when we
created the project
let's add a class named extension
so in order for our extension method to
work we must make the extension class a
static class
so we are going to add a method named
filter
the idea here is we want a way where we
can extend the functionality of any
generic list that is strongly typed with
any c-sharp data type including
user-defined types we can achieve this
by creating our own extension method so
for example if we want to filter
employee records by criteria that we are
able to specify through a Lambda
expression on a generic list that is
strongly typed as the employee
we can do this through our filter
extension method this will be
demonstrated in the calling client code
in a bit
so how do we create our own custom
extension method
so I'll first create the method
signature for the filter extension
method
first notice that our method like the
class in which it resides must be static
which is achieved by including the
static keyword
in the relevant extension methods method
signature
so if we look at the first parameter in
the filter methods method signature we
can see
that we are using for this keyword
preceding the data type of the first
parameter which is a generic list of
type t
this keyword in this context indicates
to the compiler that the relevant method
can be called on an object of the data
type of the relevant parameter in this
example that is a generic list which
contains a type T placeholder as we know
from the video series on c-sharp
generics a developer is able to pass a
data type argument to the parameter of
type T which can be any c-sharp data
type including user-defined types
the data type specified will be chosen
depending on the requirement that needs
to be met by The Calling client code
we'll demonstrate the consumption of
client-side code for the filter
extension method in a bit
so let's look at the second parameter
which is of the delegate type func for
more information about the func delegate
type please view a video created by this
channel on this topic a link to this
video is available Below in the
description
the first data type parameter passed to
the funk delegate type represents the
first data type of the first parameter
of the method referenced by the relevant
argument passed into this parameter
the last parameter in the funcdelegate
type definition is the return type of
the method referenced by the argument
passed into this parameter so the first
parameter passed into the funk delegate
is of type T and the second parameter is
of type bull
note that a predicate delegates type can
be used to define method definitions for
a method that returns a Boolean value
so we could replace the funk delegate
type with a predicate delegate type
let's use the funk delegate type but
please note that we could also achieve
the same end using the predicate
delegate type
and as you can see this method will
return a list of objects of type t to
the calling client code
so let's complete the logic for this
method let's implement the code for the
filter method
so basically we are looping through the
list on which the filter extension
method is invoked we are then adding its
elements to a new generic list also of
type T whether or not we add this list
item is based on the Boolean value
returned by a method reference passed
into the second parameter of the filter
method so the relevant method reference
is stored in the argument passed to the
parameter named funk
as you can see the method that the
variable named Funk references accepts
an argument of type t
so we are passing in each item stored in
the calling clients list
which is the generic list on which
calling client code will invoke the
filter extension method
if the method that the func variable
references returns true the items stored
in the iterated list is added to a new
list
we then return the new list containing
the filtered items to the calling client
code so this effectively means that the
calling client code is able to use our
filter method to filter any generic list
based on a method created in the calling
client code this method created in the
calling client code will contain the
logic for filtering the relevant generic
list
a reference to this method will be
passed into the second parameter of our
filter extension method and must adhere
to the method definition represented in
the second parameter of the filter
method I.E the definition represented in
the func delegate type
so we are now going to implement the
calling client code and you'll see that
the method passed into the second
parameter of our filter method will be
an anonymous method I.E a method that is
not named this method will be expressed
as a Lambda expression
we'll now see how we are able to filter
a generic list using our filter
extension method through calling client
code in the main method of our
application
right so let's go to the.net core
console project and write the calling
client code in our main method
firstly let's reference our two standard
Library projects from our.net core
console project
so let's right click the dependencies
node in the.net core console project and
tick TCP data as well as TCP extensions
so let's test our filter extension
method in a bit I'll further elucidate
why it is important to understand
extension methods and Lambda expressions
with regards to link
through the magic of how extension
methods work in c-sharp we should be
able to call the extension method on any
generic list object
so let's define a generic list that is
strongly typed as the employee user
defines type
so we have a red squiggly line under our
generic list type definition so to fix
this we need to include a directive at
the top of our code to the
system.collections.generic namespace
we can see that there is a red squiggly
line under the code that strongly types
our generic list as the user's defined
type employee
so to fix this let's include a directive
at the top of our code to the TCP data
namespace
great
so through the magic of extension
methods we should see the filter method
appear in the intellisense drop-down
list when we add a DOT after the
employee list variable
okay so why are we not seeing the filter
method appearing in our intellisense
drop-down list
the reason for this is because we
haven't included a using directive to
the appropriate namespace so let's
include a using directive at the top of
our code to the appropriate namespace IE
TCP extensions
so now if we add a DOT immediately after
the employee list variable the magic of
extension methods is revealed to us and
we can see our filter method in the
intellisense drop down list
so note that when we Open brackets to
pass in appropriate arguments to the
filter method we see that only one
parameter is required this parameter was
the second parameter we defined for this
method
so why is the first parameter in the
filter method not listed when we open
the brackets in this way
well the answer to that question is this
is how extension methods work
the consumer of the code IE the calling
client code does not need to pass in the
first parameter this is automatically
handled behind the scenes as it were
by default the first parameter is the
object on which the relevant extension
method is invoked
so in this case the list of employees
stored in the employee list variable
is passed into the filter method into
this parameter automatically
so if we look at the filter extension
method we can see that this keyword
precedes the definition of the first
parameter
that this keyword in this context
is telling the c-sharp compiler that the
argument passed into this parameter is
the object on which the relevant
extension method is invoked so we have
access to the argument passed into the
first parameter automatically
okay so the second parameter
accepts a delegate object
that points to a method that needs to be
created on the calling client so this
method that we'll create essentially
tells the filter method how we want our
list filtered
so we are able to Define this method and
the calling client code through the use
of a Lambda expression
a Lambda expression is a concise way to
represent an anonymous method if we look
at the definition of the relevant
delegate parameter we need to define a
method that accepts an argument of type
T and returns a Boolean value
so the c-sharp compiler has enough
information to infer that the intended
type for type T is employee in this
context we are calling the filter
extension method on a strongly typed
generic list the generic list is
strongly typed with the employee user
defined type
so say we want to filter our employee
list based on the value of each relevant
employee items is manager property
we want to filter the list where we only
want to return those employee records
where is manager is true
so we want to return all the records
from our list where the relevant
employees are managers
so to achieve this we can pass in this
Lambda expression
here we are telling the filter method
how we want our list filtered
let's write code to print the results to
the console screen
foreign
let's run the code
okay so we have no data
ah we of course need to populate our
employee list with data no so let's
assign the value returned from data.get
employees to the employees list variable
right let's run the code
great and you can see that only the
employee records whether relevant is
manager property value is set to true or
returned to the calling client code
great
and we can of course inject the converse
of this logic into our filter method
through the relevant Lambda expression
like this
so we are now saying we only want to
bring back employees who are not
managers let's run the code
great
and for good measure let's modify our
Lambda expression so that the filter
method only returns employees that earn
less than 50 000 a year
great
and because we have used generics for
our filter method we can call the filter
method on a list of various c-sharp
types including user-defined types so
let's prove this and call our filter
extension method on a list of
departments
foreign
let's filter the Departments based on
the Department's short name so let's
bring back the finance department and
the human resources department
foreign
let's bring back only those departments
with IDs greater than one
so the point of this is to show you the
flexibility that the combination of
extension methods and Lambda Expressions
create when writing the calling client
code
the combination of extension methods and
Lambda Expressions not only provide this
flexibility but at the same time ensure
that the calling client code is clean
and concise
once we understand how extension methods
and Lambda Expressions work they are
incredibly powerful tools
so how do extension methods and Lambda
Expressions work in relation to the
topic of this video link language
integrated query
extension methods and Lambda expressions
are fundamental to how link is
implemented in c-sharp
the enumerable class and the queryable
class are two static classes that
contain extension methods the
innumerable class and the queryable
class are both members of the
system.link namespace
so to gain access to the extension
methods provided through link we can
simply include a using directive to the
system.link namespace
without including a using directive to
the system.link namespace you can see
that we are not able to access the where
extension method provided by link to
perform our filtering operation on a
collection that implements the I
enumerable interface
so let's include the system.link
namespace
we now have access to Links where
extension method so we can now replace
our custom filter extension method with
the where link extension method like
this
we don't need to create our own filter
extension methods to perform such
queries on our data link has got us
covered for this
you know
link also provides us with a SQL like
query syntax so for example if we wanted
to produce a query result by joining
selected fields from data selected from
our collection of employee objects with
selected fields or field in this case
from data in our collection of
Department objects we can use Link query
syntax to perform our inner join
operation on these two collections of
data like this
and the link query we want to include
the department long name field so that
we can have a descriptive name for our
department in our results set rather
than displaying a result that only
contains the department ID which is
available in the employee type so we can
achieve this result by using the join
clause in a link query to perform our
inner join on our collection of employee
objects with our collection of
Department objects we have the
department ID property in the employee
type so we can join using this
type to the ID property which is a
member of the department type
so say we were to write the equivalent
query using transact SQL against the SQL
Server database that contained an
employee table with the same data schema
as our employee type and the department
table that contains the same schema as
our department type the transact SQL
query syntax would look something like
this
we are using an inner join to join data
in an employee table with data in a
department table
we are able to make the join because the
employee table contains the department
ID
which can be joined in our query the ID
of the department table
so you can see the similarities and
syntax between the transact SQL syntax
and the link query syntax
the link query is dealing with objects
encapsulating the employee and
Department Records
the employee list collection is like the
employee table and the department list
is like the department table in this
particular context
we have a select Clause a from clause
and a join clause in the Syntax for both
the link query and the transact SQL
query however the from clause in the
link query appears at the beginning of
the query and the select clause in the
link query appears at the end of the
query
so there are differences in The Ordering
of the Clauses When comparing the syntax
of the transact SQL query with the
syntax of the relevant link query
an advantage of link is it can be
leveraged in our c-sharp code to query
data in a standardized way
that is independent from the format of
the underlying data source the data
source could be a mongodb database a
sqlite database a SQL Server database
Etc
this will not affect the syntax of our
link queries
so the object layer provided by link can
be used for abstracting our queries of
the data from the underlying data source
and by using link we also have the added
advantage of compile time strong typing
and the type checking provided by the
c-sharp compiler
let me draw your attention to the select
clause we are able to return the data as
an i enumerable collection of anonymous
types
we are assigning The Collection returned
by the link query to a variable preceded
by the VAR keyword
beginning with c-sharp version 3
variables that are declared at method
scope can have an implicit type VAR
through the use of the VAR keyword the
c-sharp compiler is able to infer the
types included in the collection
returned from the query
so we are able to return a collection of
objects that are of an anonymous type
that we have defined directly within the
link query
Anonymous types provide a convenient way
to encapsulate a set of read-only
properties into a single object without
having to explicitly Define a type first
you can see how the use of anonymous
types can provide the developer with
flexibility and convenience when
constructing relatively complex queries
okay
note that Microsoft recommends using the
query syntax where possible as opposed
to using relevant extension methods for
the same purpose this is because of the
readability Advantage provided in the
relevant query syntax
there are however times
where you'll need to use appropriate
extension methods included within the
link namespace because some
functionality in link does not have a
query syntax counterpart
for example if we wanted to calculate
the average salary for all employees we
would need to use the average extension
method like this
the same applies if we wish to query for
the highest salary from a list of
employee records we would need to use
the max extension method like this
this functionality cannot be performed
through the use of query syntax
but where possible query syntax is
preferable
due to the code readability advantage
that this syntax provides
I hope you've enjoyed this video which
provides an introduction to link
this video was created to help with the
understanding of the fundamentals of
Link the advantages that link provides
and how we are able to implement basic
link queries in code
link provides us with an integration of
query capabilities directly into the
c-sharp language it is a very powerful
technology that decouples query logic
from relevant types of underlying data
formats link provides a layer of
abstraction that provides the developer
with easy to implement Syntax for
querying collections of objects
the relevant collection types must
implement the I queryable or generic I
queryable interface or the innumerable
or generic I enumerable interface
note that the I queryable interface
inherits from the I enumerable interface
and the generic I queryable interface
inherits from both the I enumerable
interface and the generic I enumerable
interface
a suite of extension methods and query
syntax are made available to c-sharp
developers which provide flexibility
when constructing powerful readable
queries against data encapsulated with
an appropriate c-sharp collections
this video is a basic introduction to
leveraging link in the c-sharp language
and the next tutorial we'll delve deeper
into the subject matter
[Music]
hi and welcome to the second part of a
video series on link this video is also
the second part of the seventh tutorial
in an advanced c-sharp course
link stands for language integrated
query in the first part of this video
series we looked at an overview of Link
we discussed that link is the name for a
set of Technologies based on the
integration of query capabilities
directly into the c-sharp language
in this video we'll demonstrate examples
where we'll create link queries using
methods syntax and subsequently show how
we can express the same link query using
query syntax as discussed in the
previous video in this series query
syntax is recommended because the logic
within the query syntax is easier to
read
in this video we'll look at code
examples using the following link
operators select where join and group
join we'll discuss what is meant by
Method chaining and demonstrate an
example that makes use of method
chaining in the context of a link query
we'll look at what is meant by deferred
execution of Link queries and what is
meant by immediate execution of Link
queries we'll discuss the inherent
advantages of deferred execution in the
context of Link
to further clarify our understanding of
deferred execution we'll create a code
example where we'll Implement deferred
execution for our own custom extension
method for an I enumerable type
we'll demonstrate how the c-sharp yield
keyword is implemented in the relevant
code example as part of code to
implement deferred execution
at the end of the tutorial we'll look at
the join operator and the group join
operator
we'll create code examples to help
clarify our understanding of these two
link operators
in the first part of this video series
we discussed that extension methods and
Lambda expressions are fundamental to
how Link Works
we created our own extension method for
filtering a generic list that can be
strongly typed with any c-sharp type
including user-defined types
we then demonstrated how a Lambda
expression can be created and calling
client code which enables the calling
client code to determine how the
relevant list of data must be filtered
the reason we created our own filter
extension method was to help us
understand the fundamentals of Link Link
functionality is encapsulated in two
static classes that are members of the
system.link namespace these two static
classes are named queryable and
enumerable
these classes mostly contain extension
methods
as with the previous video in the series
I'm going to demonstrate the code
examples in this video on my Mac
platform if you are using a Windows
platform the fact that I'm using visual
studio for Mac should not be a barrier
to follow along with these code examples
the code creation process is almost
exactly the same experience when
compared to implementing the same code
using visual Studio for Windows
so let's create a net core console
project
let's name this project link examples
underscore one
so to save time let's copy data related
code that we created in the previous
video of this series from the
appropriate GitHub repository
so please navigate to this URL in your
browser to access the relevant GitHub
repository
as always all urls referred to in these
videos can be accessed through
appropriate links included Below in the
description
so let's copy the data related
functionality from this repository to
the project we have just created
so in your browser window click the
directory icon labeled TCP data like
this
click the class icon labeled employee
let's copy the code for the employee
class from this page to our clipboards
like this
and simply paste the contents of the
clipboard below the program class in our
new project
let's also copy the code for the
Department class like this to our
clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
below the employee class within our new
project
let's then copy the code in the data
class to our clipboards
foreign
then paste the contents of our
clipboards below the department class in
our new project like this
so we have some red squiggly lines
within our data class
to fix this let's include a directive to
the
system.collections.generic namespace at
the top of our code like this
we are just creating throwaway code in
this video to help us understand the
relevant topics discussed in this video
so we are not too concerned with code
neatness in this video
in our main method let's create a
strongly typed generic list
that is strongly typed with the employee
user defined type let's name our generic
list variable employee list
let's assign the value returned from the
data.get employees method to the
variable we have just named employee
list
this line of code will populate the
employee list collection with made up
data that was hard-coded in the data
class in the previous video of this
series
let's define a generic list that is
strongly typed with our department
user-defined type let's name our
variable for this list Department list
let's assign the value returned from the
data.get Departments method to the
variable we have just named Department
list
this will populate the department list
collection with made up data that was
hard-coded in the data class in the
previous video of this series
so let's create a link query that makes
use of the select link operator
in order to use a link operator we of
course need to include a using directive
to the system.link namespace
for this query we want to select
everything from the data stored in our
employee list collection
we can do this by simply invoking the
select method on the employee list
object like this
the select method is an extension method
provided to us through link
we can shape our data through the use of
a Lambda expression like this
we discussed Anonymous types in the
previous video of this video series
so the select operator returns an i
enumerable collection of objects the
Lambda expression passed into the select
extension method provides an instruction
on how we wish to shape each item of
data within the returned I enumerable
collection
this is specifically expressed through
this Anonymous type
Anonymous types provide a convenient way
to encapsulate a set of read-only
properties into a single object without
having to explicitly Define a type first
you can see how the use of anonymous
types can provide the developer with
flexibility and convenience when
constructing queries
so here we are providing an instruction
that we want each item of data in The
Returned I enumerable collection to
contain a full name property which is a
concatenation of the first name and the
last name properties of the relevant
employee record and a property
containing the employee's annual salary
so let's write the code to Output the
results of this query to the console
screen
let's see the code in action
great
so if we want to filter this data we can
do this by chaining the where extension
method to our select operator like this
method chaining is a common Syntax for
invoking multiple method calls in C
sharp
each method returns an object allowing
calls to be changed together in a single
statement without requiring variables to
store the intermediate results
so the select operation will return an
innumerable collection object we can
filter this returned innumerable
collection within the same link query by
chaining the where extension method to
the select extension method
the where extension method filters the
data stored in the inumerable object
returned from the select method
through a Lambda expression passed to
the where extension method the Lambda
expression provides instructions to the
where extension method on how the data
must be filtered
once the data has been filtered through
the wear extension method and our
innumerable collection of results is
assigned to our results variable
we are then traversing our results using
a for each Loop and displaying each item
in the I enumerable collection to the
console screen
we discussed the VAR keyword which
allows for local implicit typing within
methods in the previous video of this
series please view the previous video in
this series for more details
so here we are implementing link
explicitly using the extension methods
provided by link we are using the select
operator and the where operator in a
link query
implemented using method syntax
let's run the code
great we can execute the same
functionality using query syntax
so let's comment out the previous code
and include a comment to label this code
so that we are able to refer to this
code later if need be
so let's first implement the link query
using query syntax without the where
clause
foreign
let's run the code
great
let's implement the link query
implemented using query syntax and this
time include the where Clause within the
link query using query syntax
let's run the code
excellent
and we get exactly the same result when
compared to running the query that we
implemented using method syntax
but we have constructed our link code
using link query syntax as opposed to
using relevant extension methods the
query syntax is more readable and we
don't need to chain our extension
methods as we did in the previous
example where we changed the where
extension method to the select extension
method
let's take a closer look at our query
where we used method syntax versus the
same query where we used query syntax
note that standard query operators in
our query syntax are converted into
extension Methods at compile time
so standard query operators are
essentially the same as their
counterpart extension methods
Microsoft recommends using query syntax
as opposed to directly implementing the
relevant extension methods where
possible
as discussed this is due to the
readability Advantage inherent in the
query syntax
there are times when you will need to
use extension methods directly where
equivalent query syntax is not available
we looked at a few examples of this in
the previous video of this series for
example using aggregate functionality
like for example finding the average Min
or Max annual salary for a collection of
employee records we would need to use
the respective average Min or Max
extension methods to calculate and
return the relevant values
the developer is able to execute link
queries with deferred execution or
immediate execution
so let's first understand what is meant
by deferred execution
deferred execution means that the
evaluation of an expression is delayed
until its value is required this
improves performance because only
necessary executions are carried out I.E
at the point where the relevant value is
required
let's use our last query example to
illustrate this point
so when we first assign the value
returned by our query to our results
variable
the query is not executed
it is only when we Traverse the items in
our results variable that the actual
execution takes place I.E with each
iteration of the for each Loop an
execution is performed whereby the
relevant item is evaluated and returned
from the collection
another advantage of deferred execution
is that an update to the relevant data
collection will immediately be reflected
in the results
so for example let's add a record to our
employee collection
note the salary for this new employee is
above 50 000 so this employee should
appear within our results
let's run the code
and you can see that this is proof that
the results are evaluated within the for
each Loop
and the query itself is not executed at
the line of code where the relevant
query is located
the execution of the query is deferred
until the results are traversed within
the relevant for each Loop
to further understand the concept of
deferred execution let's create a code
example where we'll Implement deferred
execution for our own custom extension
method for an innumerable type that is
strongly typed as the employee
user-defined type
let's create a static class named
innumerable collection extension methods
let's create a static method within the
static class that we have just created
and let's name this method get high
salaried employees
we discussed extension methods in the
previous video for this video series
for more information on extension
methods please access a link to this
video as discussed a link to this video
is available Below in the description
so let's implement the code for the get
high salaried employees extension method
like this
note the use of the yield keyword
you can use a yield return statement to
return each element one at a time
the sequence returned from an iterator
method can be consumed by using a for
each statement or link query
each iteration of the for each Loop
calls the iterator method when a yield
return statement is reached in the
iterator method
the relevant value in the eye
innumerable collection is returned and
the current location in code is retained
execution is restarted from that
location the next time that the iterator
function is called
let's go to our main method
and Implement a query that calls our
extension method on the employee list
collection
let's copy and paste the code that we
have already written to Traverse the
results and output the relevant data
and let's add another employee record to
the employee list collection as we did
before
foreign
and you can see that the new employee
record is reflected in the results the
results are kept up to date due to
deferred execution
note that deferred execution
re-evaluates on each execution which is
known as lazy evaluation
the converse of deferred execution is
immediate execution immediate execution
means the relevant query is executed
immediately
to execute a query immediately we need
to apply an appropriate two conversion
method to the query
so let's copy the previous code example
let's uncomment the relevant code let's
change this code so that the query
executes immediately
we can use the two list conversion
method for this purpose
we are using query syntax here so in
order for us to use the toolless
conversion method we first need to wrap
the relevant query in Brackets add a DOT
and then the to list conversion method
we are explicitly typecasting the I
enumerable value returned from the query
to the list type through the
implementation of the two list
conversion method we are also executing
the query immediately
let's uncomment the rest of the relevant
code for this example
and let's run the code
you can see that the execution of our
query is immediate because this time
after we've added a new employee the
query has not been evaluated again to
include the new employee record and the
results this is of course why the new
employee does not appear within the
results output to the screen
this proves that our query has executed
immediately at the line of code where
the query is located
and remember that query syntax does not
support two operators so we need to wrap
our query in Brackets as we have done
here and call whichever two method is
appropriate for example to list two
array or two dictionary
by calling the relevant to method in
this case the two list method we are
causing our query to execute immediately
without the two conversion method the
relevant query execution would be
deferred until the relevant results are
iterated
so let's move on to the join operator
and then we'll look at the group join
operator and highlight the difference
between these two join operations
in the previous video in this series we
looked at the join operator and
discussed how we can perform an inner
join on two inumerable collections using
a link query
so here we have two collections that we
wish to join in this specific use case
we need to include a descriptive
Department name in our results displayed
to the user we only have a department ID
field in our employee type so in order
to merge the properties from our
employee type with the relevant property
from our department type we need to join
records of type Department that reside
within our department list collection
with records of type employee that
reside within our employee list
collection we can do this by matching
the ID field in the department records
that reside in the department list
collection with the Department ID
property of employee records that reside
in the employee list collection
we can do this through link by using the
join operator
later we'll demonstrate a join operation
but using the group join operator we'll
also discuss the differences between the
join operator and the group join
operator
let's look at the relationship between a
collection of Department Records with
the collection of employee Records
Department Records have a one-to-many
relationship with employee records
a specific Department can have many
employees as members
a specific employee cannot belong to
more than one department at a point in
time
data collections can also have
one-to-one relationships with one
another or many too many relationships
with one another so in this example we
are going to look at how we can use Link
to implement a join operation between
two collections of records that have a
one-to-many relationship with one
another I.E one Department to many
employees
so let's Implement a query that joins
the department list collection with the
employee list collection where the ID
property of the relevant objects of type
Department match the department ID
employee
so the Syntax for this link query would
look like this when we implement the
join operation using method syntax
so to join Department Records to
appropriate employee records we can use
the join extension method and invoke the
extension method on the department list
collection
the first argument we need to pass into
the join method is the collection on
which we want to join the department
list collection
so we pass in the employee collection
object here
the second argument is the key from the
outer collection the department list
collection so the outer join key is the
ID property that resides in the
department type we can express this
argument as a Lambda expression like
this
the third argument is the inner join key
which is the department ID property
which is a member of the employee type
we can express this argument as a Lambda
expression like this so we are joining
on the ID property which is a member of
the department type with the Department
ID property which is a member of the
employee type
we can define an anonymous type where we
are able to shape the data for each item
in an i enumerable collection that we
want returned from the relevant query
here we are defining an anonymous type
within our link query that includes the
employee full name which is a
concatenation of the employee's first
name and last name the employee's annual
salary as well as the relevant
Department objects long name property
the long name property will give us a
descriptive Department name in our
results
we are including the department types
long name property and the relevant
Anonymous type this is the whole point
of joining the department list
collection with the employee collection
so that we are able to include a
descriptive Department name within our
results we only have the department ID
as a member of our employee type so if
we only return to results from the
employee list and wanted to include
Department information we would be
restricted to the department ID property
which is an integer value and is
unlikely to be meaningful to a user
foreign
thank you
let's run the code
great
but as discussed where it is possible to
use Query syntax rather than method
Syntax for our link queries
we should use Query syntax because the
logic expressed and the relevant query
is far easier to read
so let's write the same query using
query syntax
okay
foreign
as you can see it is far easier to read
and it is also similar to query
languages with which we may already be
familiar for example transact SQL let's
Express what a similar query and
transact SQL might look like
so let's imagine that we have a table in
a SQL Server database that could map to
our employee type
let's say this table has the same name
as our employee type let's also imagine
that we have a table in the same SQL
Server database that contains a table
schema that could map to our department
type
let's say this table has the same name
as our department type
so the transact SQL would look something
like this
you can see how the from Clause the join
clause and the select Clause are
implemented in both the link query
syntax and the transact SQL syntax
even though the link query contains the
same Clauses in a different order to the
comparative Clauses in the transact SQL
query for someone who is familiar with
transact SQL and not necessarily
familiar with link query syntax this
link query syntax at a glance should be
fairly easy to understand
so the point here is that link query
syntax is similar to query syntax with
which many of us will already be
familiar so this makes the
implementation of Link queries using
query syntax more intuitive
as discussed the link query syntax is
also more readable than the equivalent
link query implemented using method
syntax so the key takeaway here is to
use Link query syntax rather than method
syntax where possible because it is more
intuitive to implement and easier to
read
let's run the code
great
so let's look at the group join link
operator and while we might want to use
the group join operator in our link
queries
we have just performed an inner join
using the join operator this query will
only return those records based on the
ID property of relevant objects of the
department type in the department list
collection matching with the Department
ID property of relevant objects of the
employee type in the employee list
collection diagrammatically an inner
join query can be represented like this
what if we wanted to return through a
link query all the Department Records in
our department list collection and only
employee records where the department ID
property of employee objects and the
employee list collection match the ID
property of Department Records in the
department list collection so if we were
to write to the transact SQL version of
this query it would look something like
this
we would use a left outer join to
achieve the desired result
this query would bring back all
Department Records but only those
employee records where the relevant
employee records department ID values
match the ID property of the relevant
Department Records
so diagrammatically we can represent a
left outer join query like this
so let's look at the diagram
representing an inner join operation and
compare the diagram to the diagram
representing the left outer join
operation
so let's use our group join operator in
a link query to return all Department
Records from the Department list
collection but only the employee records
from the employee list collection with a
department ID property that matches an
ID property of a department record in
the department list collection
so here we are implementing our query
using method syntax
you can see the implementation of the
group join operation using method syntax
is very similar to The Way We
implemented the join operation in the
previous example
let's run the code
note the way we have structured our
output is clearly different when
outputting the results of our group join
query when compared to the way we
structured our output of the results of
our join query but note that at the
moment the same join between Department
Records and employee records has
occurred
the reason for this is not because the
group joined and the join operators
perform the same type of join operation
it is because currently each of the
records in the employee list collection
match with a department record in our
department list collection
let's change our data to highlight a key
difference in the join operation and the
group join operation
let's do this by going to the code where
we have hard-coded made up employee and
Department Records and added these
records to their respective collections
let's ensure that the technology
department which has an ID of three does
not match with a department ID property
of any of the employee objects in our
employee list collection
we only currently have one employee that
is in the technology department
according to our data let's change the
relevant Department ID so that there are
no employees that are members of the
technology department so let's change
this department ID property now no
employees are members of the technology
department according to our data
let's run the code
so you can see our technology department
record is being returned along with all
the other department records in the
department list collection even though
its ID property doesn't match the
department ID property of any employee
records stored in the employee list
collection
so simply put Department information for
departments that contain employees are
included in the query results and
departments that don't contain any
employees are also included in the query
results
in this example the technology
department has returned even though it
contains no matching employee records
so here we have performed a left outer
join query using links group join
operator
so let's rewrite this link query using
query syntax
you can see here that the group join
extension method does not get explicitly
called when we Implement our query using
query syntax the into keyword is used
within the query to create a group of
employees for each department
so as discussed link query syntax does
not match exactly when comparing link
query syntax to familiar query languages
like transact SQL but in many ways it
does resemble a language like transact
SQL in this sense link query syntax is
more intuitive to implement than method
syntax when implementing link queries
and just to labor the point as discussed
it is also better to implement link
query Syntax for our link queries then
implementing method Syntax for the same
purpose because of better readability
let's run the code
great and we get the exact same result
as when we ran the same query that was
implemented using method syntax
now that we have changed the data so
that the technology department does not
match with any employee records let's
run our join operation that we created
earlier
notice that the results of the join
operation doesn't include the technology
department this is because the join
operation performs an inner join and
with the group join operation we are
able to perform a left outer join
operation
so let's comment out our join query and
uncomment our group join query
and for good measure let's run the code
again
and as you can see the technology
department is now included in the
results displayed to the screen even
though the technology department does
not have any matching employee records
great
so the left outer join operation returns
all records from the outer left
collection in the query but does not
return records from the inner collection
where the inner collection records do
not match any of the outer collection
records
so if there were employee records in the
employee list collection that did not
match any of the Department Records in
the department list collection these
employees would not appear in the
results outputted to the screen we can
prove this let's change the department
ID of this employee record where the
first name property is Bob and the last
name properties Jones
we have changed the department ID
property for this record to six and
there's no matching Department record
I.E no Department record has an ID of
six let's run the code
and you can see that the employee record
with first name Bob and last name Jones
does not appear within the results
however even though the human resources
department has no matching employee
records it is still included in the
results output to the screen great let's
add Bob Jones back into the human
resources department like this and let's
run the code
excellent
so hopefully this made it clear how we
are able through link to use the join
operator to perform inner join queries
between two object Collections and how
we are also able to perform left outer
join queries using the group join
operator
[Music]
foreign
to the third part of a video series on
the link technology using c-sharp this
video is also part of the seventh
tutorial in an advanced c-sharp course
link was introduced with c-sharp version
3 which was released on the 19th of
November 2007.
link stands for language integrated
query
in this video we are going to focus on
code examples that make use of several
link operators
the code examples demonstrated in this
video will hopefully help us gain an
understanding of a broad array of
operators that are made available to us
through link
we'll learn how we can use these
operators to query and transform data
this quote from the Microsoft docs
provides a basic definition of standard
query operators and can be found at this
URL
the standard query operators are the
methods that form the link pattern most
of these methods operate on sequences
whereas sequence is an object whose type
implements the generic I.E numerable
interface or the generic I queryable
interface
a lot of the more frequently used query
operators have dedicated c-sharp keyword
syntax that enables them to be called as
part of a query expression as discussed
in the previous video in this video
series it is advantageous to use Query
syntax rather than method syntax where
possible because query syntax is more
readable note that query expression
Clauses are translated into calls to
query Methods at compile time
for a useful tabular representation of
standard query operators that have
equivalent query expression Clauses
please navigate to this URL we discussed
what is meant by deferred execution and
immediate execution in the previous part
of this video series
for a useful tabular classification of
operators in terms of deferred execution
or immediate execution please navigate
to this URL
for additional information on deferred
execution versus immediate execution and
Method syntax versus query syntax please
View the second part of this video
series
so to gain an understanding of several
useful link operators let's create a few
code examples
as with the previous video in this
series I'll be demonstrating these code
examples on my Mac platform using visual
studio for Mac
the code creation process for these code
examples is almost exactly the same
process as creating the equivalent code
examples on a Windows platform using
visual Studio for Windows
the fact that I'm using visual studio
for Mac should not be a barrier for a
learner to follow along with the
creation of these code examples
start by creating a.net core console
project
we created a project in the previous
video named link examples underscore one
let's name this project link examples
underscore 2.
in order to save time let's copy data
related classes that have already been
created in the previous videos of this
series and incorporate these classes
into our new project these classes
contain class definitions for an
employee and a department record as well
as code that adds several made up
objects of type employee and Department
to their respective collections
as in the previous parts of this video
series we can then use these collections
of strongly typed objects in our link
query examples
so to copy the relevant code let's
navigate to this URL I.E to a GitHub
repository that was created in the
previous video
let's click on the directory icon
labeled link examples underscore one
then let's click on the file icon
labeled program.cs
let's copy the employee class to our
clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
within the new project that we have just
created
let's copy the department class to our
clipboards and paste the contents of our
clipboards below the employee class
within our new project
lastly let's copy the data class to our
clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
below the department class within our
project
so in the previous video we looked at
the following operators
the select projection operator the where
filter operator the join and group join
join operators in this video we'll
create code examples that implement the
following operators
we'll start by looking at the following
sorting operators order by order by
descending then by and then by
descending
we'll then look at these grouping
operators Group by and to lookup
we'll then look at these quantifier
operators or any and contains
we'll then look at the following
filtering operator of type
note that another example of a filtering
operator is the where operator we have
looked at the where filter operator in
the previous parts of this video series
lastly we'll look at the following
element operators element at element at
or default first first or default last
last or default single and single or
default
we'll look at even more link operators
and create code examples in the next
video
the next video will be the final video
in this video series on link
right let's get started so let's start
by looking at the data related classes
that we copied from GitHub we have the
employee class which provides a
definition for an employee record we
have the department class which provides
a definition for a department record
we have the data class that contains
code where lists of hard-coded made up
employee and Department objects are
added to their respective collections
within their respective methods and
returned from their respective methods
in the previous video in this series we
looked at join operators namely the join
operator and the group join operator
so in the context of join operations the
department collection has a one-to-many
relationship with the employee records
in the employee collection
this simply means that one or many
employees can be members of a specific
Department a specific employee can be a
member of only one department at a point
in time
so let's go to our main method
we can use the data dot get employees
method to return a collection of made up
employee records
let's use this method to assign the
relevant collection of employee records
to a local variable named employee list
the employee list variable is defined as
a generic list that is strongly typed as
employee
so here we have red squiggly lines
because we need to include a using
directive to the
system.collections.generic namespace
let's use the data dot get departments
method to return a collection of made up
Department Records that have a
one-to-many relationship with the
relevant collection of employee records
and let's assign the relevant returned
collection of Department Records to a
variable named Department list
the department list variable is defined
as a generic list that is strongly typed
as Department
so let's get into the creation of our
examples
sorting operators order by
so let's create an example for the order
by operator in this example we want to
return all employee records from the
employee list collection and order by
Department ID
to make things a little bit more
interesting let's say we want to include
the department name within our outputted
results
the problem here is that the department
name does not exist in the employee type
so we need to join the employee list
collection to the department list
collection so that we can include the
department name in our results
we can do this by using the join
operator
so let's write this query using method
syntax so that we can see all the link
extension methods used in the relevant
query
so we first need to make sure that we
include a using directive to the
system.link namespace this director will
give us access to the relevant link
operators that we will be implementing
in our code examples
we know that the system.link namespace
contains two static classes namely
innumerable and queryable and these
static classes mostly contain extension
methods our link operators which are
implemented in the form of extension
methods are implemented within the
enumerable and queryable static classes
so this link query joins the employee
list collection to the department list
collection on the department ID property
of each of the relevant employee records
with the ID property of relevant
Department Records
foreign
before we run this query let's alter the
data a bit let's make the employee
record pertaining to Sarah Jameson a
member of the technology department by
changing the relevance Department ID
property from two to three let's also
change the department for the employee
record pertaining to Jane Stevens to the
technology department by changing the
relevance Department ID from 2 to 3.
this change to the data will make the
effects of our sorting operators more
apparent when we view our results
so if we run the query first without the
use of any order by operators note that
the data appears to us in the same order
as it was added to the employee list
but now let's say there is a requirement
to order our results by the department
ID property in ascending order
we can do this by chaining the order by
extension method to the end of the query
like this
for more information on method chaining
please view the previous video in this
series
so we can pass in a Lambda expression to
the order by extension method to
indicate that we wish to order the
results by the department ID property
let's run the code
and you can see that the results are now
ordered in ascending order by Department
ID
if we look at the code that added each
department to the department collection
we can see that the human resources
department has an ID of one the finance
department has an ID of two and the
technology department has an ID of three
our results have been ordered in
ascending order based on the department
ID property of the employee record
so we can clearly see the effects of the
order by operator on our results great
if the requirement changed such that we
needed to order our results by the
department ID property in descending
order we can chain the order by
descending extension method instead of
the order by extension method for this
purpose
our results are now ordered by
Department ID in the reverse order when
compared to the previous output great
so let's say that we want to order our
results by the department ID property in
ascending order and then by the annual
salary property also in ascending order
so let's replace the order by descending
extension method with the order by
extension method in our results like
this then let's chain the then buy
extension method to the query like this
we can then pass a Lambda expression to
indicate that we wish to further order
our results by the annual salary
property the then by extension method
will order the results produced by the
order by sorting operator in ascending
order
great
and if we want to order by the annual
salary property in descending order we
can replace the then buy extension
method with the then by descending
extension method for this purpose
excellent
we can represent sorting operations
within link queries that are represented
using query syntax like this
note the order by and descending
keywords in the query syntax version of
the relevant query
we use the order by keyword within our
query to order by our first specified
property
if we want to subsequently sort on other
properties instead of chaining the then
by extension method to our query and
query syntax subsequent Properties by
which we wish to sort are separated by
commas
the descending keyword can follow any of
the properties that we wish to sort in
descending order
the default order is ascending order
thank you
so let's look at the group by and to
lookup grouping operators
let's start with the group by operator
so this operator is akin to the group by
Clause we would apply in a transact SQL
query
so we can implement the group by
operator using the group by extension
method or the group and the buy keywords
within query syntax to perform the same
operation
so let's say we wish to query the
employee list collection
and group our results by the department
ID property
the query using query syntax would look
like this
this query is simply grouping our
results by the department ID property
using method syntax this query would
look like this
in all of the link query examples using
query syntax that we have looked at up
till this point in this video series we
have ended all our queries with a select
operator
notice that this query does not end with
a select operator
it is important to note that a link
query implemented in query syntax must
either end with a select operator or a
grouping operator
notice how this query does not end with
a select operator but a grouping
operation is being performed at the end
of this query
so we can Traverse the results of this
grouping operation using nested for each
Loops the outer loop traverses each
group that has been created based on the
department ID property the inner loop
traverses the item members within each
of the groups that have been created in
our query based on the department ID
property
great
we could also include the order by
operator within our query like this
let's run the code
great
we can implement the same query using
methods syntax using the to lookup
extension method like this
great
we can also include sorting
functionality through the order by
operator through the implementation of
method chaining like this
great
note that the two lookup method performs
the same operation as the group by
operator the only difference is the
execution of the group by operation is
deferred whereas the execution of the
two lookup operation is executed
immediately
we discussed deferred execution and
immediate execution in the previous part
of this video series for more
information on deferred execution and
immediate execution please View the
second part of this video series the
link to this video has been included
Below in the description
note that the results returned from a
group by operation and a two lookup
operation return a group contained in a
special type of collection that
implements an eye grouping generic
interface
so let's look at the all any and
contains quantifier operators let's
first look at the all and any operators
let's create a variable named annual
salary compare and assign it with a
value of twenty thousand
let's Implement a block of code related
to the all operator
let's Implement a similar block of code
related to the any operator
so the all and any operators return a
Boolean value
the return value will equal true if the
elements in the relevant collection
satisfy a condition passed to the
relevant method this condition can be
passed in the form of a Lambda
expression
this query will return true if all
employee records
have annual salary property values that
are greater than twenty thousand
this query will return true if one or
more employee records have an annual
salary property value that is greater
than twenty thousand
let's run the code
foreign
this is an expected result
let's change the annual salary compare
variable to a hundred thousand
great
and let's change the annual salary
compare variable to 40 000.
so let's move on to the contains
operator
so we want to be able to assess whether
an employee record exists within our
collection of employee records
the contains operator will return true
if we pass in an object that is equal in
value to an object within the relevant
collection
to understand how the contains operator
Works let's create an employee record
that we know matches an employee record
within the employee list collection
let's copy this record for the employee
named Douglas Roberts that is a member
of the relevant employee collection
and paste it in our main method
let's name the variable that stores a
reference to the employee record we wish
to find within the employee list
collection search employee
so how can we assess whether the
employee record pertaining to Douglas
Roberts exists within the employee list
collection
we can use the contains extension method
we can simply pass the variable we named
search employee to the contains
extension method which we have invoked
on our employee list collection object
so the contains method returns true if
the search employee object matches any
of the objects within the employee list
collection and false if the search
employee object does not match with any
of the objects stored within the
employee list collection
so let's write code to write an
appropriate narrative to the screen
based on the Boolean value returned by
our query
let's run the code
and this is not the result we expected
because we literally copied and pasted
the code representing one of the
employee objects that has been added to
the employee list collection from our
data class to the main method as our
search object so why is our output
indicating that the search employee
object does not match any of the objects
stored within our employee list
collection this result is unexpected
the answer is that the compiler knows
how to compare built-in C sharp types
like for example integer or bull
the employee type is a user-defined type
or custom type we need to tell the
compiler how we wish to compare two
objects of type employee to establish
where the two employee objects are equal
so we can do this by creating a class
that implements the generic I equality
comparer interface
the eye equality compare interface is a
member of the
system.collections.generic namespace
we have already included a using
directive to this namespace within our
code
so let's create a class named employee
comparer and let's indicate that we want
the employee comparer class to implement
the I equality compare a generic class
that is strongly typed with the employee
user-defined type
so let's hover our Mouse pointers over
the red squiggly line and create the
stubs for the methods that we need to
implement like this
so two method stubs have been generated
one named equals and the other named get
hash code so the get hash code method is
used for the purpose of uniquely
identifying an object we can implement
the code for the get hashed code method
by returning the hash code of the ID
property of the relevant employee object
like this
the equals method must be implemented in
a way that establishes how we wish
employee objects to be compared when
determining whether two employee objects
are of equal value
so let's say that we are satisfied with
comparing the relevant employee objects
based on their ID first name and last
name properties to establish equality
between the relevant employee objects
so we can achieve this with the
following code
if the relevant properties are equal
return true else return false
so we are already passing in the search
employee objects to the contains method
let's also pass a newly instantiated
object of type employee comparer to an
overload version of the contains method
like this
and now we are telling the compiler how
we want to compare our employees search
object with the objects stored within
the employee list collection
let's run the code
and this is an expected result the
contains method now returns true as
expected because our search record
matches the employee record for Douglas
Roberts within the collection on which
we are performing our search great
so now let's look at the of type filter
operator so before we use the of type
filter operator in our code examples
let's create a method named get
heterogeneous data collection
heterogeneous in this context of course
is referring to the storage of objects
of multiple different data types within
the same collection
so we can store objects of multiple
different data types in an arraylist
note that Microsoft does not recommend
using arraylists for new development it
is far better to use strongly typed
lists to store collections of data
for more detail as to why strongly typed
lists are recommended please view a
video on generics created by this
channel a link to this video has been
included Below in the description
so a use case where we could apply a
link query on an arraylist could be
perhaps we have a legacy piece of code
that includes an arraylist containing
objects of multiple types and we need to
filter the relevant arraylist based on
specific types
we can achieve this using the of type
link operator
we'll look at how we can do this in a
bit let's first add some made up data to
an arraylist
so the arraylist stores integers strings
objects of the employee user defined
type and objects of the department
user-defined type
foreign
let's go to our main method and write
code to use the of type operator to
query this arraylist based on specified
data types
let's query for all string values in our
arraylist
great
so let's query all integer values in our
array list
foreign
great let's query for all objects of the
employee user defines type
department user defines type
excellent
so you can see how we can query an
arraylist for objects of a specified
type using generics and the of type
Operator by passing in the relevant type
between angle brackets like this
this will return those objects within
the arraylist that are of the specified
type
let's move on to the element operators
let's look at the element at element at
or default first first or default last
last or default single and single or
default element operators
so let's first look at the element at
operator
so the element at operator is used for
querying for an item in a collection
that resides at a specified ordinal
location within the relevant collection
so we can pass an integer value
representing the relevant element's
location in the relevant collection into
the element add method to return the
desired items value from the relevant
collection like this
great and our query has returned the
value for the relevant element
foreign
but what happens if we pass in a value
representing a position in the relevant
collection where an element does not
exist so let's try this let's pass in a
value of 8.
right so it is important to note that no
item exists within the relevant
collection at ordinal position 8. so in
this case an argument out of range
exception is thrown
this brings us to an important point
about the difference between the element
at and the element at or default method
if we replace the element at method with
the element at or default method and we
query the relevant collection for an
item at a position where the desired
item does not exist within the relevant
collection the element at or default
method does not throw an exception
but rather Returns the default value for
the desired items relevant data type
let's briefly discuss what we mean by
default value for a particular data type
the c-sharp language Associates default
values for c-sharp data types so if for
example we are querying a collection of
integers using the element at or default
method for a value that did not exist at
the specified location in the relevant
collection the element at or default
method would return the default value
for the integer data type which is a
value of zero
the integer value of 0 is the default
value for the integer data type in C
sharp if however we are querying a
collection containing a reference type
object like an object of our
user-defined type employee the default
value returned by the element at or
default method would be null null is the
default value for reference type data
types like user-defined types or the
string data type
for more detail regarding default values
in c-sharp please navigate to this URL
so let's use the element at or default
method to query the relevant collection
of employees for a value at position 8.
I.E where no employee object is present
within the relevant collection we can
then write code to check if the returned
value is null
and you can see that an exception is not
thrown and no results are outputted to
the screen which is an expected result
because the query returned a null value
let's pass in a value of 2
thank you
and then one
and in both cases the appropriate result
is outputted to the screen
so let's write code to Output an
appropriate narrative to the user based
on the value returned from the element
at or default method
so let's pass in a value of 12.
the output indicating that the return
value is null I.E the employee object
does not exist in the collection as
output to the screen this is an expected
result great
so the first operator Returns the first
element in a collection if no condition
is specified we have the option of
passing a condition to the first method
or we can leave the brackets following
the first method empty if we do not
specify a condition the query will
return the first element in the relevant
collection if a condition is specified
the first operator will return the first
element in the collection that satisfies
the specified condition we can specify a
condition in the form of a Lambda
expression right to prove this let's
first create a strongly typed list of
integer values
foreign
this collection using the first operator
and don't provide a condition passed as
an argument to the first method
the query Returns the first item in the
collection as expected
so let's pass a condition in the form of
a Lambda expression to the first
extension method
so this condition is simply querying the
collection for the first even number in
the collection
let's run the code
great
but now what happens if we alter the
collection of values so that no value
satisfies the condition I.E no even
numbers exist within the relevant
collection
an invalid operation exception is thrown
so if we don't want an exception to be
thrown we can replace the first operator
with the first or default operator
as you may have guessed
where no items in the relevant
collection satisfy the relevant
condition this method will not throw an
exception but will rather return the
default value of the relevant data type
we know that the default value for the
integer dates type is zero
let's write code to Output an
appropriate narrative to the screen if
the relevant condition is not satisfied
let's run the code
and this is an expected result
so let's include an element in the
relevant list that does satisfy the
condition
excellent
so the last and last or default
operators work in much the same way as
the first and the first or default
operators the only difference is that
the last item in the collection is
returned where no condition is specified
the last item that satisfies a specified
condition and the collection is returned
when a condition is specified
the last method will throw an exception
if an appropriate element is not present
within the relevant list
we can use the last or default method
rather than the last method to return
the default value for the relevant data
type in the case where an appropriate
element in the relevant collection is
not present
great so let's move on to the single and
single or default element operators
the single operator Returns the only
element in a collection or one element
that satisfies a specified condition
from a collection we have the option of
passing a condition into the single
method through the use of a method
overload or we can leave the brackets
following the single method empty which
means we have chosen not to pass in a
condition into the single method
if we choose not to pass in a condition
into the single method and there is more
than one element or zero elements in the
collection and invalid operation
exception will be thrown if however
there's only a single element in the
collection the value for this element
will be returned by the query
if we do choose to pass in a condition
and zero or more than one element
satisfies the condition an invalid
operation exception will be thrown
if we pass in a condition to the single
method and only a single element
satisfies the condition the value for
this single element will be returned
from the relevant single operation
let's apply the single operator to a
collection of employees
let's first modify the data for our list
of employees so that only one employee
element exists within the relevant
employee collection
foreign
let's write code using the single
operator to query the relevant employee
list
foreign
this is an expected result
let's now include the employees that we
just commented out back within the
relevant employee list
let's run the code
and an invalid operation exception is
thrown as expected this is because more
than one employee resides in the list
if there is only one item in the
relevant collection the value for this
item is returned
if there are zero items or more than one
item in the collection and the condition
is not specified for the single operator
and invalid operation exception is
thrown
so let's test the single method and this
time specify a condition where one item
within the relevant collection satisfies
the specified condition
great
let's specify a condition where more
than one item in the relevant collection
satisfies the specified condition
as you can see an invalid operation
exception is thrown
so let's test the same scenario I.E more
than one element in the relevant
collection satisfies the specified
condition but this time let's use the
single or default method
that's interesting
so note where more than one element
satisfies the specified condition when
the single or default method is applied
in the relevant query an invalid
operation exception is thrown just like
when the single method is applied to
perform the same operation
so we can use the single or default
method instead of the single method if
we don't want an exception to be thrown
under the scenario where no elements
exist within the collection the default
value for the data type will instead be
returned by the query
if a condition is specified for the
single or default method and no elements
satisfy the condition the same result
will be produced I.E the default value
for the data type of the elements stored
in the collection will be returned by
the query
if a single item is present within the
relevant collection and the single or
default method is applied to perform a
query against the relevant collection
the single elements value that exists
within the relevant collection will be
returned by the query
[Music]
hi and welcome to the fourth and final
part in this video series on the link
technology using c-sharp this video is
also part of the seventh tutorial in an
advanced c-sharp course
this video is a continuation of the
previous three videos in this video
series on link so I recommend viewing
the previous three videos in this video
series before viewing this video
in the previous video in this series we
looked at code examples where certain
link operators were implemented to query
and transform data this video is a
continuation of the previous video in
this series where we'll create code
examples using some of the other link
operators to gain a broader
understanding of what can be
accomplished using the Link Technology
in c-sharp so in the previous videos in
this series we have created code
examples using the following link
operators
the Sorting operators order by order by
descending then buy and then by
descending the grouping operators Group
by and to lookup The quantifier
Operators all any and contains
the filter operators of type and where
the element operators element at element
at or default first first or default
last last or default single and single
or default the join operators join and
group join
we have already looked at the select
projection operator and we'll also look
at the select operator in this video and
in addition to this we'll also look at
the select many projection operator
so in this video we'll look at the
following link operators the equality
operator sequence equal
the concatenation operator concat
the set operators distinct except
intersect and Union
the generation operators default of
empty empty range and repeat operators
the aggregate operators aggregate
average count sum and Max
the petitioning operators skip skip
while take and take while
the conversion operators to list two
dictionary and two array
and lastly the projection operators
select and select many
we'll also look at the following
keywords that are useful when used in
queries implemented in query syntax
namely the let and into keywords
we have looked at the select projection
operator already in previous videos but
we'll look at this operator again in
this video as well as look at the select
mini projection operator we'll then be
able to gain an understanding of the
difference between the select and the
select many projection operators
as in the previous videos I'll be
demonstrating the code examples on my
Mac platform if you are using a Windows
platform to follow along the experience
of creating these code examples will be
almost exactly the same so the fact that
I'm using visual studio for Mac should
not be a barrier for a learner using
visual Studio for Windows to follow
along with the creation of these code
examples okay so let's create a.net core
console project
foreign
so the official release of dotnet 5 has
now been released so I'll be running
this project using the new.net5.net
runtime
for more information on the significance
of the.net 5 runtime please View the
second part of this Advanced c-sharp
course I've included a link to this
video Below in the description
the project we created in the last video
was named link examples underscore 2.
let's name this project link examples
underscore 3.
so as we did in the previous video let's
navigate to this URL where we can access
code on GitHub for the project that was
created in the previous video of this
series
here we can copy the data related code
that we created in our previous project
so that we can reuse these data related
classes in this project
let's click the directory icon labeled
link examples underscore 2.
let's then click the file icon labeled
program.cs
let's copy the class named employee
and paste the contents of our clipboards
to our new project
let's do the same for the Department
class
and the data class
okay so we won't be using the get
heterogeneous data collection method
that resides in the data class in this
video so let's delete this method
let's refresh our memories about the
classes we have just copied and pasted
from GitHub the employee class contains
a definition for an employee record
the department class contains a
definition for a department record
the data class contains hard-coded made
up data for employee records and
Department Records the employee records
are stored in a generic list strongly
typed as employee the Department Records
are stored in a generic list that is
strongly typed as Department
we can access the data stored in the
employee list collection from calling
client code in this case this will be
the main method by calling the static
method named get employees we can access
the data stored in the department list
collection by calling the static method
named get departments note that the data
class in which these methods reside is a
static class
let's navigate to the main method and
before we create our example code let's
add the appropriate using directives
first let's add a using directive to the
system.collections.generic namespace
the generic list type is a member of
this namespace
let's also add a using directive to the
system.link namespace once we have added
our system.link using directive we can
access our link operators on collection
types that implement the I enumerable
interface so for example list types
implement the innumerable generic
interface so we are able to access
extension methods stored within the
innumerable static class which is a
member of the system.link namespace by
including a using directive to the
system dot link namespace
the queryable static class also includes
link extension methods and is a member
of the system.link namespace for more
information on how extension methods
work in c-sharp please view the first
video in this video series a link to
this video has been included Below in
the description
before we get started creating our code
examples I want to draw your attention
to what might be an issue for visual
studio for Mac users when we run our
code interactively through Visual Studio
for Mac by default the output may appear
in the terminal console window within
visual studio for Mac like this
this is absolutely fine for testing code
but you may prefer to present the output
externally I.E in a terminal console
window outside of visual studio for Mac
if you'd prefer to present your output
externally I.E outside of visual studio
for Mac please navigate to visual studio
format preferences then Under The
Heading marked other select the item
labeled terminal
in the right pane of the relevant dialog
box ensure that the enable integrated
terminal checkbox is unchecked
this is obviously not a functional issue
it really comes down to personal
preference
let's define a generic list variable
named employee list that is strongly
typed as employee and let's assign the
collection of employee records returned
by the data dot get employees static
method to the employee list variable
let's define a generic list variable
named Department list that is strongly
typed as department and let's assign the
collection of Department Records
returned by the data.get department
static method to the department list
variable okay so we are now ready to
query and transform data using link
so let's start with the equality
operator sequence equal
so the use case here is we want to
compare two lists of data and we want to
know if these two lists contain elements
of equal value and each element in each
of the relevant lists are stored in the
same order if each item in each list
matches in terms of value and order the
sequence equal method will return true
if any of the items in each of the
relevant lists does not match in terms
of value and order the sequence equal
method returns false let's create a
generic list named integer list one
that are strongly typed as integer let's
copy and paste this line of code to the
next line let's change the name of the
second list to integer list 2.
let's run the code
and the sequence equal method returns
true because the values and sequence of
elements in integer list 1 is identical
to the values and sequence of elements
in integer list 2.
let's change the order of the items in
integer list 2 so this sequence of
values is not equal to the sequence of
values stored in the list named integer
list one
let's run the code and this is an
expected result
let's change integer list to once again
for good measure
and this is an expected result great
so let's change the data in instillus 2
so that the order and values in the
lists are equal
and now the result is true which is an
expected result
that was pretty straightforward I.E
comparing two sequences of values of a
primitive data type IE the integer data
tab but what if we want to test this
type of equality between two lists that
are strongly typed with a complex type
like for example our employee uses
defined type
so let's Define a variable named
employee list compare as a generic list
type that is strongly typed as employee
and let's assign The Collection returned
from the data dot get employee's static
method to our employee list compare
variable
let's run a sequence equal operation and
compare the values stored within our
employee list compare collection with
the values stored within the employee
list collection
so one would expect the result of the
sequence equal operation to return true
because both collections contain exactly
the same data let's see what happens
oh and false is returned
the reason why false is returned is
because we need to tell the compiler how
to establish equality between objects of
the relevant complex type IE in this
case the employee type so we achieved
this in the previous video in this
series by implementing the built-in I
equality comparer generic interface so
let's copy the relevant code for this
that we implemented in the previous
video in the series
let's navigate to the GitHub repository
at this URL that contains the code we
created in the previous video in this
series
let's copy the class named employee
comparer to our clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
to our projects like this
we have red squiggly lines so let's fix
this by bringing in the appropriate
using directive so here we have
implemented a class named employee
comparer that implements the generic I
equality compare interface that is
strongly typed as employee
this gives us a way of telling the
compiler how we want objects
in our lists of type employee to be
compared when determining equality
between the relevant objects
so we are explicitly doing this here in
the equals method where we are comparing
the ID first name and last name
properties between two employee objects
we are returning true if the relevant
properties of the relevant two objects
are equal and false is returned if any
of the relevant properties of our two
objects are not equal within the get
hash code method we are returning the
hash code of the ID property of the
relevant employee objects for more
information on hash codes please
navigate to this URL
so now let's go to our main method and
we can pass in a new instance of the
employee comparer class to an overloaded
version of the sequence equal method
this object will tell the compiler
explicitly how we want our employee
objects to be compared
let's run the code
and now the sequence SQL operator works
as expected so note that we need to tell
the compiler how we want objects that
are defined as complex types to be
compared when determining equality
between the relevant objects
we can do this by creating a class that
appropriately implements the I equality
comparer generic interface great
let's move on to the concatenation
operator named concat
we can use the concat operator to append
one collection of data to another
collection of data
so let's see the concat operator in
action let's create a collection of
integer values
let's then create another collection of
let's append the second collection of
integer values with the first collection
of integer values using the concat
operator
let's write code to Output the results
of this concatenation operation to the
screen
let's run the code
great
let's do another example but this time
let's append a collection that contains
a collection of objects of a complex
type to another collection of objects of
the same complex type the complex type
we'll use in this example will be our
employee user defined type
once again we can use the concat
operator to achieve what we want here
let's run the code
great
let's move on to the aggregate operators
let's first look at the aggregate
operator
using the aggregate operator we can
perform a custom operation on values
within a collection
let's say we have a requirement where we
need to provide a total for the annual
salaries of our employee records
we also need to include the addition of
an appropriate annual salary bonus in
the final result let's say a manager
gets a bonus of four percent and
employees that aren't managers get a
bonus of two percent so let's say we
have a use case where we need a result
that is a total of all employee annual
salaries which must include each
employee's bonus
we can take this added complexity into
account when totaling up our employee
annual salaries through the use of the
aggregate operator
so the first argument is the seed value
so let's provide zero for this argument
using this argument we are initializing
the value that will be returned by our
aggregate operator
the next argument is of a delegate type
where we can include the logic for our
aggregation functionality in the form of
a Lambda expression so as you can see in
our Logic for the relevant Lambda
expression argument we are checking to
see if the relevant employee is a
manager whereby we need to add a bonus
of four percent to the relevant
employees annual salary if the employee
is not a manager we need to add a bonus
of two percent to the relevant employees
annual salary
we can then include the appropriate
bonus amount in our calculation so we
are adding up all employee annual
salaries which includes each employee's
appropriate bonus
let's run the code
great
say we want to Output a comma delimited
string from our employee list collection
each delimited item containing the
employee full name a dash then the
employee annual salary each annual
salary must include the appropriate
bonus
we also want to include a label
preceding the comma delimited string
we can achieve this using the aggregate
operator like this
the first argument is the label where an
appropriate value could be something
like employee annual salaries including
bonus
then the logic of our aggregation
functionality
can be expressed in a Lambda expression
for the second argument like this
we can apply the same logic to include
appropriate bonuses from our previous
example
let's run the code
great but we have a slight issue where a
comma is presented at the end of our
string
we don't want this comma in our final
result
we can express this by passing a Lambda
expression as our third argument to an
overloaded version of the aggregate
operator
this argument allows us to perform a
final operation on the results produced
by the Lambda expression passed in as
the second argument
we first need to include another data
type argument with an angle brackets
following the aggregate method to
declare the data type of the final
output I.E provided by the Lambda
expression we are passing in to the last
parameter of this overloaded version of
the aggregate method
in the Lambda expression passed in as
our final argument we are using the
substring method to remove two
characters from the end of the result
which means a comma and a space will be
removed
this result is what we want excellent
so let's move on to the average
aggregate operator
so to find the average annual salary for
a list of employees we can apply this
code
great if we want to find the average
salary for all employees in the
technology department we can use method
chaining and the where operator to
achieve this like this
great
for more information on method chaining
please View the second part of this
video series
let's move on to the count aggregate
operator
so if we want to know how many employee
records we have in our collection of
employee records we can apply the count
operator like this
great
if we want to know how many employees or
members of the technology department we
can pass in a condition as an argument
to the count operator
the condition that is passed in as an
argument to the count method can be
expressed in the form of a Lambda
expression
great
let's move on to the sum aggregate
operator
so let's keep this simple we just want
the sum total of all annual salaries of
all employee records stored in our
employee list collection we can apply
the sum operator to achieve this
great
let's move on to the max aggregate
operator
so if we want to return the highest
annual salary property of all employee
records stored in our employee list
collection we can apply the max
aggregate operator in a link query like
this
great
let's move on to the generation
operators namely default of empty empty
range and repeat
let's first look at the default fmt
operator
so we can use the default if empty
operator to return a new I enumerable
collection that when for example we
apply the element at method on the new
collection to check if the new
collection is empty the operation will
return the default value for the
relevant type used to strongly type the
relevant collection
a query using for example the element at
method against a collection returned
from a default of empty operation will
not throw an exception if the collection
is empty the default value of the type
with which the relevant collection is
strongly typed will instead be returned
for more information on default values
for C sharp dates types please navigate
to this URL
we'll see later how we can pass in a
value to the default of empty method to
specify our own default value that we'd
prefer to be returned when for example
the element at method is used to check
if the relevant collection is empty
rather than the default c-sharp value
for the relevant data type
let's look at an example using the
default fmt method
so let's create an empty list of integer
values let's perform a default fmt
operation on this collection of integer
values and assign The Returned
collection to a new collection of
integer values let's use the element at
operator and pass in 0 to the element at
method to check if the collection is
empty
you can see that the element at operator
Returns the default value for the
integer data type which is zero this is
an expected result let's create another
example but this time let's use the
employee data type to strongly type our
collections as discussed the default
value for a reference type in c-sharp is
null
but as discussed we can pass in a
default value that we would prefer to be
returned by for example the element at
operator when the relevant collection is
empty
so let's person an employee object where
the ID property of the relevant employee
object is set to zero
null is not returned as would be the
case if we hadn't passed in a value to
the default fmt method because we have
specified our own default value where
the ID property of the default employee
object is zero
great
similarly we could have set the default
value for our integer collection example
by for example passing in
999999 to the default if empty method
instead of returning the default c-sharp
value for an integer which is zero nine
nine nine nine nine nine is returned
this is an expected result excellent
right let's look at the empty method
so we can use the empty method to
generate a new empty collection
so for example we want to create a new
innumerable generic collection of
employee records we can do this by using
the empty operator like this
note the empty method is not an
extension method of a numerable or I
queryable like other link methods it is
a static method included in the
enumerable static class
so for example we could instantiate a
new empty generic list strongly typed
with the employee user defined type
through the use of the empty method
we can then chain the two list
conversion operator to this operation
and return an empty generic list we are
using the two list operator to convert
an i enumerable generic collection that
is strongly typed with the employee
dates type to a generic list that is
strongly typed as employee
so for good measure let's add a new
employee item to our new list that we
have generated through the use of the
empty method and the use of the two list
conversion operator
let's write code to write the items or
in this case one item stored in our new
list to the screen
great
let's move on to the range generation
operator
we can use the range operator to return
a collection of values that are within a
specified range so let's clarify this
with an example
we want to return a range of integer
values in a collection where the first
item in the range has a value of 25 and
each subsequent item is incremented by a
value of 1 until there are a total of 20
values in the relevant collection
we can achieve this by using the range
method like this
in this example the first argument
specified is 25.
this is the value of the first element
and the second argument specifies the
number of elements to include in the
relevant generated collection
when each item is added to the
collection It Is incremented by a value
of one so the second item will be 26 the
third item will be 27 the fourth item
will be 28 and so on
let's run the code
great so using the range operator we
have generated a collection of integer
values that fall within a specified
range excellent
let's say we want to generate a
collection of a specified amount of
elements where a value for each element
in the collection is repeated
we can use the repeat operator for this
purpose like this
great
let's move on to the set operators
namely distinct except intersect and
Union
let's start with distinct so let's say
we have a strongly typed generic list
that contains a list of integer values
some of which are repeating values we
want to perform a query against this
list of integer values where we only
want distinct values returned
we can achieve this by applying the
distinct operator to our query like this
great
let's say that we have two collection of
a specific type and we want to return
elements with values in our first
collection that are not equal to any of
the values of the elements in our second
collection we can achieve this by using
the accept operator let's look at an
example of using the accept operator
applied to two collections of integer
values
so one and two are returned in our
results collection because these values
exist in our first collection and don't
exist in the second collection
the values 3 and 4 exist in our first
collection and also exist in our second
collection
the values five and six exist in our
second collection and even though these
items don't exist in our first
collection
the accept operator does not return
these items as part of the results
collection because in this example the
accept operator returns values that
exist in the first collection and don't
exist in the second collection
let's try an example using complex types
let's use our employee type
let's create a generic list strongly
typed as employee
let's copy data
that we know will exist within our
employee list collection and add these
items to the list we have named employee
list 2. let's add some additional items
to the employee list to collection
let's then call the accept method on the
employee list collection and pass in the
employee list 2 collection as an
argument to the accept method then let's
assign the results of this operation to
an implicitly typed variable named
results we have of course used the VAR
keyword to implicitly type our results
variable
let's write code to Traverse the results
and output the results to the screen
let's run the code and see what happens
and this result is not expected the
output contains all items within the
employee list collection
I would have expected that the items
that were copied from the data class and
added to the employee list 2 collection
as well as the other items that we added
to the employee list collection would be
excluded from the results
the reason for the unexpected results is
because we have not told the compiler
how to compare employee objects when
determining if one employee object is
equal to another employee object
so how can we let the compiler know how
we want one employee to be compared to
another employee within our collections
when determining equality between the
two relevant objects
you may have guessed already how we can
achieve this we first need to create a
class that implements the IE quality
comparer generic interface
we can then write code to establish how
one employee object should be compared
to another employee object when
determining equality between the
relevant objects
we have already included the code for
this which we applied when we created
code to perform a sequence equal
operation on two lists that were
strongly typed as an employee so we have
our class named employee comparer that
implements the IE quality comparer
generic interface
so we can reuse this class for our
example that performs an accept
operation on two generic lists that are
strongly typed as employee
so all we need to do is create a new
object of type employee comparer and
pass this object into an overloaded
version of the accept method like this
let's run the code
great
this is now an expected result let's
move on to the intersect operator
so we can use the intersect set operator
to return a collection containing only
those items that exist in the employee
list collection that are equal to the
items that exist within the employee
list 2 collection
and now that we know we are comparing
elements in two collections that are
strongly typed with the employee complex
type we need to pass in a new object of
the employee comparer type I.E a type
that appropriately implements the
generic IE quality comparer interface
this tells the compiler how to compare
two objects of type employee when
determining if the relevant employee
objects are equal let's run the code
and this is an expected result great
let's move on to the union operator the
union extension method requires two
Collections and returns a new collection
that includes distinct elements from
both the collections
we can again use the same data we have
used in the previous two examples to
test the union operator right let's
write the code for this you will notice
we are also passing in an object of type
employee comparer to the union method
Let's test the code
great
so let's see what happens in this
example when we don't pass in an object
of type employee comparer to the union
method
you can see that duplicate records are
included in the results as a consequence
of not passing in an object derived from
a class that appropriately implements
the generic I equality comparer
interface and of course we know we have
already created such a class so let's
ensure that we pass in our object of
type employee comparer to the union
method so that only distinct employee
objects are included within our results
excellent so let's move on to the
partitioning operators these
partitioning operators include the skip
skip while take and take while operators
let's first look at the skip operator
use the skip operator to skip over a
given number of elements in a sequence
and then return the remainder
so let's query our employee list
collection using the skip operator
let's skip over two of the elements
stored in our employee list collection
and return the remainder of the elements
using the skip operator
great this is an expected result
let's look at the skip while operator
using the skip while operator bypasses
elements in a sequence as long as a
specified condition is true and then
Returns the remaining elements
let's see this operator in action
so the condition here is Skip elements
in our sequence of employee objects in
the employee list collection while the
relevant employee object's annual
salaries are above 50 000.
great this is an expected result
just to make things a little bit more
clear on how this operator Works let's
add a new employee record to the
employee list collection this employee
record has an annual salary of 100 000
which of course is above fifty thousand
let's run the code
and you can see that while the condition
is true the items in the relevant
collection are skipped I.E will not be
returned from the query however all
subsequent elements in the sequence will
be returned once the condition returns
false
even though the last element in the
relevant sequence has an annual salary
property greater than fifty thousand it
is still returned because the third
element in the sequence caused the
condition to return false
the fact that the last element has an
annual salary above 50 000 and therefore
causes the condition to be true doesn't
mean that the last item will be returned
by our query note that once the
condition returns false all items from
that point will be returned from our
query
right let's move on to the take
partition operator
the take operator is used to return a
specified number of contiguous elements
from the start of a sequence
let's see this operator in action
this is an expected result great
the first two elements in the relevant
sequence of elements in our employee
list collection are returned by our
query
so let's move on to the take while
partitioning operator
the take while operator returns elements
from a sequence as long as a specified
condition is true and then skips the
remaining elements
so let's use the same condition that we
used in the skip while operator example
so here we are using the take while
operator to return elements from the
relevant sequence that have an annual
salary above 50 000.
so the first two elements in the
sequence are returned by our query
as soon as the third element is
evaluated and the condition returns
false the elements from that point
onwards in the relevant sequence will
not be returned by our query
so for example the fact that the fifth
element in the employee list collection
has an annual salary property that is
greater than 50 000 is irrelevant
because when the third element causes
the condition to return false and in
terms of the take while operator this
means that from that point onwards the
rest of the elements and the relevant
sequence will not be returned by our
query great
let's look at the conversion operators
to list two dictionary and two array
so let's look at the two list conversion
operator a query written in query syntax
will return an i enumerable collection
containing the results of the query what
if we need our results to be returned as
a generic list
we can achieve this using the two list
conversion operator
let's create an example to clarify this
point
so for this example let's query our
employee list collection for employee
records that have an annual salary
property greater than fifty thousand
using query syntax
note the red squiggly lines here
this is because we are attempting to
assign an inumerable collection to a
variable of type generic list
the compiler is telling us that we have
created a type mismatch
so we can use the two list operator to
convert the I enumerable collection
returned by our query to a generic list
by wrapping the relevant query in
Brackets adding a DOT after the last
bracket and applying the two list
operator like this so now you can see
the red squiggly lines disappear because
we have removed the type mismatch
let's run the code
excellent
as discussed earlier in this video
series wherever a two conversion
operator is applied to a query as we
have done here
this causes the query to execute
immediately I.E query execution is not
deferred it is executed immediately
so if we want to convert an innumerable
collection returned from a query to a
dictionary object
we can apply the two dictionary operator
to the query let's create an example to
clarify what is meant by this so as in
the previous example here we have a
standard query written in query syntax
to query our employee list collection
for all elements where the relevant
elements have annual salary properties
that have values greater than fifty
thousand so this is a basic query that
will return an i enumerable collection
but what if we want to return a
collection where each element has a
unique key associated with the relevant
element
we can do this by converting the query
result to a dictionary generic
collection type
so let's alter our code so that the
innumerable collection returned by our
query is converted into a generic
dictionary collection So within angle
brackets after two dictionary we need to
pass in two data types the first data
type declares the data type of the
values stored in the dictionary
the second data type declares the data
type of the key that will be used to
uniquely identify each element in the
collection so the First Dates type is of
type employee and the second data type
is of type int note that we want each
element to be keyed on the employee ID
property
we can express this by passing in an
appropriate Lambda expression to the two
dictionary method like this
so let's Traverse the key values stored
in our dictionary object using a for
each Loop
note how we are able to use the key
values to retrieve the values of each
element stored in the dictionary
we are doing this by passing in the
relevant key within square brackets to
the dictionary object
here we are outputting the key as well
as each employee's first name and last
name to the screen
and as you can see we have each
employee's ID which we have designated
as our key value followed by the
corresponding employees first name and
last name properties excellent
we have successfully converted a query
result from an innumerable collection to
a dictionary object
as discussed when we call any of the two
conversion operators on a query result
this causes our query to execute
immediately for more information on
deferred execution versus immediate
execution please View the second part of
this video series
for good measure let's also create a
result using the two array conversion
method
so if we try to assign the results of
this query to a variable defined as an
array of employees the compiler
complains of a type mismatch the query
result is returned as an innumerable
collection and not an array of employee
objects
to remove the type mismatch we can apply
the two array method like this
great
so let's discuss the let and the into
Clauses that can be applied when using
query syntax to represent a link query
let's look at the Microsoft docs for an
overview of the let Clause this overview
of the let Clause can be found at this
URL
in a query expression
it is sometimes useful to store the
result of a sub-expression in order to
use it in subsequent clauses
you can do this with the let keyword
which creates a new Range variable and
initializes it with the result of the
expression you supply
once initialized with a value the range
variable cannot be used to store another
value
however if the range variable holds a
queryable type it can't be queried
so let's look at a basic example using
the let keyword in a link query
let's say we wish to query our employees
based on employee initials now we don't
have an initials property for an
employee record but within our query
using the let keyword we can extract the
initials from each employee records
first name and last name properties and
assign the result
of this extraction process to a variable
named initials directly within our query
using the let keyword this allows us to
use the initials variable in our where
Clause as well as reuse the initials
variable within our select clause
through the use of the let Clause we can
also apply a condition and based on the
evaluation of that condition store a
value in a variable that can be used
later in the query like for example
within aware clause
here we have a condition where we need
to add an appropriate bonus to the
annual salary property based on whether
the employee is a manager or not a
manager if the employee is a manager we
need to add a bonus of four percent to
the relevant employee records annual
salary property if the employee is not a
manager we need to add a bonus of two
percent to the relevant employee records
annual salary property we can store the
relevant annual salary plus bonus value
for each employee record by assigning
the value returned by a ternary operator
to a variable we have named this
variable annual salary plus bonus the
let clause in this example enables us to
reuse the annual salary plus bonus
variable both within the where clause
and the select Clause later in the query
thank you
foreign
let's run the code
excellent
let's look at the into keyword
we can use the into keyword in a link
query to collate data within a group and
then after this operation we are able to
perform a filter operation within the
same query if required on the grouped
data through the use of aware clause
so for example let's use a link query to
First create a group of high earning
employees based on a condition let's say
that the employee must earn above 50 000
to fit into the relevant group we can
use the where Clause at this point in
the query to appropriately filter the
relevant employee records and the into
keyword to put the filtered data into
the relevant group of high earning
employees
so we can use the into keyword to group
The High earning employees into a group
named High earners let's say we then
want to further filter this group of
high earning employees by management
status
so we only want these employee records
where the is manager property is set to
true return from our query
we want to know which of those High
earning employees are managers
so we can use another where Clause
within our query to filter the high
earner group based on the relevant
condition
we have used a where Clause earlier in
our query to create the group of high
earning employees
then once the group is created through
the use of the into keyword we can
further filter the group of high earning
employees based on each employee records
is manager property
so we are able to include another where
clause in our query to filter the
grouped data let's run the code
great
so lastly let's look at the select and
the select many projection operators
in this video series we have already
looked at the select projection operator
so the focus in this example is on the
select many operator
we want to know how it differs from the
select operator and in what
circumstances we may wish to apply the
select many operator in a link query
let's navigate to a Microsoft docs
webpage to see what the Microsoft docs
say about these two projection operators
projection refers to the operation of
transforming an object into a new form
that often consists only of those
properties that will be subsequently
used
by using projection we can construct a
new type that is built from each object
you can project a property and perform a
mathematical function on it you can also
project the original object without
changing it
select projects values that are based on
a transform function
select many projects sequences or values
that are based on a transform function
and then flattens them into one sequence
to understand the difference between the
select many operator and the select
operator let's modify our department
class so that it includes a property
that stores a collection of employees
we have already discussed that
Department Records have a one-to-many
relationship with employee records so
each department object will now store a
collection of related employee records
let's also alter the get Department's
static method that resides in the data
static class so that the get
Department's static method accepts an
argument containing a collection of
employee objects
then for each department object added to
the department list collection within
the get Department static method let's
include a query to return an appropriate
collection of employees I.E those
employee records that have a department
ID property matching the ID property of
the relevant Department object
so let's go to the main method and pass
in the collection of employees to the
get Department method so now the get
departments method will return a
collection where each department
contains a related collection of
employee records
so now what if we want to query the
department list collection for all
employees we can achieve this using the
select operator but when traversing the
results of the select operation we will
need to use an outer and an inner for
each Loop like this
in this scenario the select many
operator is better to use for this
purpose the select many operator is
better in this case because we can use
one for each Loop to Traverse the
results of our query
unlike where we needed to use an
additional nested for each Loop to
Traverse the results of our query where
we used the select operator
behind the scenes as it were the select
many operator appropriately flattens the
results
and this means we don't need to use a
nested for each Loop to Traverse the
results of our query
we are able to use one for each Loop for
this purpose
excellent
so we have covered a lot of ground in
this video series on link operators I
would encourage you to practice using
these operators to become proficient in
writing link queries this is a very
powerful technology and it's used with
Entity framework to perform database
queries in modern.net applications
Entity framework is now the recommended
technology to use a.net for implementing
database related functionality in.net
applications if we navigate to this
Microsoft docs webpage we can see this
paragraph that states Entity framework
core is a modern object-based mapper
for.net it supports link queries
change tracking updates and schema
migrations EF core works with many
databases including SQL database
on-premises and Azure sqlite MySQL
postgres and Azure Cosmos DB
this makes link a very important
technology to learn for net Developers
link enables developers to write one set
of code that can be applied to handle
data related functionality for multiple
different data sources in link
expression trees are used to represent
structured queries that Target sources
of data that implement the generic I
queryable interface
if you would like to delve deeper into
expression trees please navigate to this
URL
so let's summarize what we have learned
in our four part series on using the
Link Technology in C sharp in the first
part of this video series we created our
own extension method to filter data we
also demonstrated how a Lambda
expression can be used to express a
condition that can be passed into our
extension method to filter the data and
return the filtered results from a query
the reason we created the filter
extension method is because link is
mostly made up of extension methods
stored in two static classes namely a
static class named enumerable and a
static class named queryable
we are able to access the extension
methods Within These static classes by
including a using directive to the
system.link namespace the innumerable
and queryable classes are both members
of the system.link namespace
in the second part of this series we
demonstrated examples using the select
where join and group join operators we
also discussed the difference between
when a query is executed with deferred
execution or immediate execution we
discussed how a link query is executed
with deferred execution but we can make
the link query execute immediately by
applying a two conversion operator to
the query for example two list two
dictionary or two array
in the third video in this series we
demonstrated code examples using the
following link operators
sorting operators order by order by
descending then buy and then by
descending grouping operators group buy
and to lookup
quantifier operators or any and contains
filter operators of type and where
element operators element at element at
or default first first or default last
last or default single and single or
default
in the fourth and final video in this
series we demonstrated code examples
using the following link operators the
equality operator sequence equal
the concatenation operator concat
the set operators distinct accept
intersect and Union
the generation operators
default if empty empty range and repeat
operators
the aggregate operators aggregate
average count sum and Max
the partitioning operators skip skip
while take and take while
the conversion operators to list two
dictionary and two array
projection operators
select and select many
in this video we also looked at code
examples using the let and the N2
keywords
I hope you've enjoyed this video series
on using the Link Technology in c-sharp
I hope you enjoyed this part of the
advanced c-sharp course where we looked
in a fair amount of detail at a set of
Technologies named link
please find the full Advanced c-sharp
course on the gavinlan YouTube channel
you'll see the video series on the home
page the playlist for the entire
Advanced c-sharp course can be found at
this location
I hope to see you soon thank you and
take care